how long you in for good after nearly
six months teaching prisoners to cook in
Brixton prison
I'm still trying to persuade a major
retailer to stock a lemon treacle slice
if a big order comes in my remaining
workforce need to deliver but I've just
found out I'm about to lose yet another
valuable member of my team
people go back up to say worth nothing
but should I yeah heroin addict poor
wires were sentenced to eight months for
stealing 50 quids worth of steak from
Sainsbury's to pay for his drug habit
after being in prison for four months
he's just been approved to release don't
start taking drugs thinking y'all gonna
be a junkie if you can control it no
anyone can really deep down
your eyes your I've witnessed my younger
brother triumph failed to go clean
countless times so spoken to my
restaurant manager had the Savoy Grill
and decided to give Paul a chance
I can't give you a job just like that
yeah within 48 hours that's just not
going to happen but what I am going to
do next week is arrange for a trial to
spend a day in the kitchen and if you do
keep your head down stay focused and you
prove to me to my HF and it goes very
well because the job at the end of it I
don't want you in limbo because that's
where the temptation starts and I've
been close to it for 15 years and I can
tell you every rehab every secondary
house every halfway house every program
and every pickup for meth within 25 mile
radius alone let me tell you you're the
only person to screw this up and if you
do buy me our pork can I know Joey give
me that charge and that I'll grab it of
both legs I'll unscrew up Thanks when
Paul left school he studied at college
to become a chef but he didn't finish
the course this is his big chance it's
all shot I've just taken it over leaner
than my mother yeah it's like let's say
so yeah I'm waiting and just gonna keep
keep me motivated or even better
if Paul sticks to his word I'll be
working with him on the outside he said
I got I'm hoping the bad boys bakery's
loss will be the Savoy grills gained
this course has made me happy inside
makes me want to get up for the morning
makes me want to strive to to be someone
to do something to demonstrate the
professionalism of my team
the Wellington has to be cooked
perfection oh that's good